an historic neighborhood is now a little  more recognizable with the addition of  brand new street sign toppers they were  unveiled today in the paradise palm  neighborhood of desert and eastern the  neighborhood is full of mid-century  housing once home to many celebrities  and entertainers and the county thought  it was time to recognize that history  this is part of revitalizing old las  vegas you know so much time we spent  building roads and freeways to get  people out of downtown out to the  suburbs to summerlin to east las vegas  now we're going to try to bring bring a  little energy back downtown and kept  these neighborhoods up  the signs were paid for by neighbors  just the first step is other  neighborhoods across the valley will  also be labeled as historic in the  future